hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Super Mario maker
now we're halfway through the challenge
with more than half our lives left which
typically means that we're gonna be okay
and I even got a normal controller
instead of the gamepad which might make
it just a little bit easier to get
through this challenge or it's gonna
[ __ ] me hinder me I'm gonna cry into
my body pillow tonight
it's just sobbing helplessly anyway so
oh no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no okay all right I
already don't like this oh okay
ah that was unnecessary but I did it
anyway because I like to laugh I like to
live I like to live okay so this at
least this one's not as bad as the spiky
one that we've seen in prior levels
because that one was just a load of
Ditka tree so if I can just get through
this with minimal loss of Shroomish it
did it anyway so I don't even know if
what I did was very skillful but I'm
gonna assume that I'm doing okay oh I
might be able to get one of those guys I
jumped right into that there was no
point to anything I was doing besides
doing that okay but I saw another way
down there was like a fire flower over
on the left hand side so I can just do
that there's no way to avoid that there
but there is
just a little too much live too much pop
okay so there is a way down on the right
path over here that I can see stop
throwing things right down there so if
I'm oh [ __ ]
Oh what the hell how did I fall through
I don't even know what just happened
okay so if I damage boost through there
I should be able to make it all the way
to the end and I'm hoping then I'm gonna
do this in a timely manner because I've
already lost quite a few lives oh yes
[ __ ] okay just speed speed speed done
okay so get that so I just gotta get
through here without losing okay here we
go I don't I don't know how that worked
before okay there we go got it and then
there's a oh [ __ ] I guess I gotta lose
one more but that's okay yes okay I've
got this does this help me oh [ __ ]
I'm wasting it I'm wasting it I'm
wasting all of my potential oh [ __ ] Oh
No
I'm wasting it oh god I wasted it I
wasted it all I wasted it so much oh why
did I Oh
I've only lost four lives on this one
level which means that I've got a lot
more I was not even frickin paying
attention there of looking at another
screen it doesn't matter there I'm just
doing what I can to get by here so long
as I'm going quick enough shouldn't be
Oh Frick no [ __ ] god damn it oh man I
don't even know where the other way to
go was it was like down the right crack
of that I think it can fall down I
didn't try it there because I'm stupid
okay off you go
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh god damn it it's too close
oh it's so scary
oh hello just a situation have been
throwing it blindly from above [ __ ] now
I've gotta go oh man this one is hard I
thought for in the beginning that it was
gonna be manageable and okay but this
one is actually there's actually not
that difficult the only problem area is
just the unpredictability see like that
okay so that is apparently a solution
just can't get through them okay it
doesn't matter as long as I grab this
star then go come on there god damn it
just to spike me up there grundle but I
can get through this it's not a big deal
oh don't waste it oh this is exactly the
definition of wasting it what the hell
happened here okay I do this level is
odd it's oddly made it's the rules are
little bizarre [ __ ] oh really
really I'm gonna go get that because
there's no point otherwise okay oh
really oh really oh really oh really
[ __ ] you get out of my way [ __ ] off
I should have twirled jumped god I
should've jumped
oh that's okay I think I got it this
time
is at least I'm going to be more
coordinated the problem areas see just
like that and just like that I already
know what I'm doing it's just that I
haven't been doing it properly I know I
know
I don't even know why I would go for
that get bad see just with the back and
the VATS okay oh [ __ ] it's probably like
right there the end is probably right
there it's right there isn't it I'm not
gonna lose it all here no no no no no no
they're all gonna laugh at you okay fine
it's fine it's for you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you [ __ ] why would you do that why
would you define goddamnit why would you
do that
Oh fifty god damnit fifty I've lost
sixteen on this level alone I just want
to get through the expert challenge I
don't want to start over again God how
hard is that to understand just get it
God just get it just get it Oh sassafras
oh [ __ ] Oh ah this is unreal why is this
so hard for me it's not that hard this
ludus really really this one's not that
hard but for some reason it's given me
connections connect passions oh [ __ ] you
man [ __ ] you [ __ ] right off with this
okay there we go see it would have been
so easy if I just gotten here but I got
the other the people like up my ass with
oh [ __ ] off with that just there we go
[ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
I'm coming for you [ __ ] you what is this
what is this what is this oh [ __ ] off do
not kill me how see it looks like
someone just spewed randomly but it what
there yes okay good
I got it [ __ ] it even prevented me from
getting a one-up seems like someone just
randomly spat [ __ ] here and hope for the
best
this was not planned this level had no
planning this level is [ __ ] and I
hate it and I got the world record [ __ ]
that oh my god alright I must start the
next one and then if it's not good right
off the path and I'm just gonna rock it
rock it rock it at least I did it I
didn't I didn't I didn't give up I got
44 left to go to the end and I'm hoping
I'm gonna get someone ups here oh this
looks interesting I'm breaking out here
you sacks of crap
[ __ ] you all so far so interesting oh
hello okay yeah they'll never see me in
this disguise oh I forgot I can't jump
or I can't criss cross Joe okay
well this seems rather precarious what
happens if it goes bad oh [ __ ]
don't woo don't lose it [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
no oh no oh no oh I can't get through if
I don't get that oh that's such dick a
tree I should have held onto it anyway
but goddamnit
okay so I got you I got you I understand
you I'm gonna give this one more try in
this playthrough and then I'm not gonna
quit on it I'm just I'm just saying
go to different ventures okay this time
don't be a fool don't be a goddamn fool
like that nope yeah freaking fool okay
so hopefully I'm just gonna gun straight
to them cap them out like so and then
get the new one here and then I'll be
good
then just avoid the bullet bongos be
something short enough that I don't need
to worry about that that's awfully handy
that is pop boy okay
boink and boink okay so far so Q we okay
follow these guys in it's so still T
you'll never know that I'm here chase
this guy down there's oh that looks like
deathly fire down there I always like
deathly fire why did I come up here
probably for nothing they still have
this okay I'm assuming this is just
gonna be another mush okay whoa I didn't
actually expect to make it through there
well that looks precarious and dangerous
how are we gonna avoid all that death
okay the guard dog is being whoa that
ain't good okay you did nothing useless
says it could be okay go fire quickly
look nope not ain't gonna do it get next
time this time
risking it yes okay so so far it's not
that bad am I supposed to know no way no
way I'm supposed to go up here with this
woo hey whoa watch it with those things
you put someone's eye out
whoa [ __ ] [ __ ] off yes okay that's
something at least is something okay oh
there we go Oh freedom let's hope I
don't die okay so this is a faith jump
I'm gonna go for this
oh and to 1ups how about vat jazz so
thank you everybody so much for watching
I made it through two levels but that
first one was a notch but I got through
it so thank you again now as always I
will see you in the next video god it's
so weird